big news out of the January 6th
committee the house January 6th
committee investigating the Trump riots
will have their next session after kind
of a summer break on Wednesday and I
will try to cover that live schedule
permitting the big news and Business
Insider has a good article explaining
what's going on January 6th committee
members say they believe Trump was
responsible for the riot and the panel
might unanimously refer Trump for
prosecution this would be a really big
deal it doesn't mean he would be
prosecuted and if he were it doesn't
mean he would be convicted and if he
were it doesn't mean he would go to
prison but let's just start where we are
the highlights from this Business
Insider report January 6 committee
members Schiff and Cheney spoke about
the capital Riot investigation on Sunday
they said they both believe Donald Trump
committed wrongdoing but they said the
panel will give a unanimous verdict
either way when it decides whether to
refer Donald Trump for prosecution so at
the tail end of this uh committee and
the series of hearings
the committee members will vote and they
will say are we referring Trump for
criminal prosecution or not and what
Schiff and Cheney are saying is it will
be a unanimous verdict we won't come out
with a split verdict we will all decide
much like a jury
um Schiff said he will make the decision
his decision aligned with the rest of
the committee so that they act
unanimously we operate with a high
degree of consensus and unanimity so
there's a couple interesting things here
that I want to discuss and how much we
talk about this ahead of the actual
decision it's going to be limited
because it's just going to be a matter
of waiting and seeing this is less about
whether Donald Trump actually ends up in
prison again I do not believe Trump will
end up in prison I think even if you go
to the end of the rainbow to speak
metaphorically to the conclusion to all
of these in criminal investigations even
in the event of a criminal conviction
with a sentence
as a former president Trump will serve
it out in one of his Resorts I mean just
he's not going to end up in prison
and for me this is actually less about
whether he even is given any prison time
that's like 10 steps away this is more
about another criminal problem for Trump
as he considers running for 2024 and
will it impede him from carrying out
such a campaign we already know that
Donald Trump has been sued and
criminally referred in New York by the
Attorney General Leticia James we talked
about that last week we know that as a
result of the FBI search warrant served
at Mar-A-Lago
that is likely a criminal investigation
that is moving well ahead and rather
quickly that's another legal problem we
know about what's going on in Georgia
where Donald Trump remember he needed I
need 11 000 votes give me a break a
probable
um uh wrongdoing there potentially
charges come so the question is now with
the addition
um of a potential criminal referral from
the January 6 committee is this just
going to muck up his trying to run in
2024. now I get it many of you are like
oh David come on
six years of this and nothing it's but
bombshell after bombshell
and yet nothing as we continue to see
evidence of Trump's wrongdoing I'm with
you I'm with you and if I had to issue a
defense for why we should remain
cautiously optimistic and again I'm not
even sure that we should but if I wanted
to make that case the four years Trump
was in office he was protected to some
degree by his own Attorneys General he
had a completely corrupt in his pocket
Republican party who even if they didn't
love Trump they weren't going to say
much about it publicly other than the
rare handful of folks like you know Mitt
Romney and this ridiculous you know some
of them call it a rule it's really sort
of like a uh what a tradition I don't
even know where the Department of
Justice doesn't indict sitting
presidents and some Republicans arguing
the Department of Justice really
shouldn't even investigate sitting
president so that's all gone now so now
what Trump is dependent on or Reliant
upon is can can corrupt judges save him
and the truth is
there could have been a federal Trump
indictment anytime since January for the
Mueller probe if they wanted to do that
a January of 2021 but they haven't he's
no longer a sitting president the
evidence is all still available so I
share everyone's sort of skepticism but
I try to maintain some degree of
cautious optimism and in the next three
months particularly I mean we're only
six five and a half six weeks away from
the uh six weeks from the midterms there
is the belief that after that there may
be action but I I'm with you guys you
know I'm I'm not naively wide-eyed and
bushy-tailed uh holding my breath for
these indictments they clearly should
come but whether they will we will find
out let me know what you expect find me
on Twitter at dpacman after the break
I'm actually going to have for you some
positive examples of how Democrats need
to be talking about the tomfoolery of
the Republican Party stay with us